It's a horrible stomach pain from
not eating anything at all and that's when
you realize that this idea starts to arise in
everyone at the same time and it starts
to arise in everything without anyone talking
to them. The first comment I'm
sorry.  parrado when I tell him there is
nothing left in the pantry which was where
we kept that can of seafood and and
Carlitos tells me I like the pilot who
also when we received the news on the
10th that they were no longer looking for us uh
when it starts to emerge in everyone  At the
same time, the only possible idea
is to feed on our
dead companions because there is no other
chance. The first thing we made was a
solemn pact between all of us that
if any of us died, he would be at the
disposal of the others.